الدبابات القادمه من الغرب مفتاح سحريه في
المعارك تبحث عنه اوكرانيا الاعين
الاوكرانيه على الدبابات تشالنجر من
بريطانيا ودبابات ابرامز من الولايات
المتحده
اثنين من المانيا
تقريبا معادلات على الارض وان تعزز التقدم
البريه الاوكراني لخصوصا في المناطق
الجنوبيه والجنوبيه الشرقيه هذه الحاجه
تنتقل الان من الدفاع الى الهجوم تتجاوزكي
الحديث عن استعاده مساحات من القبضه
الروسيه الى استهداف شبه جزيره القرد توضع
شبه الجزيره الجنوبيه على الطاوله احد
الاهداف القادمه للقوات الاوكرانيه رغم
السيطره الروسيه عليها منذ عام 2014
[موسيقى]
الى اوكرانيا بحاجه الى موافقه الدوله
المصنعه
تقترح عدد من الدول الاوروبيه في الناتو
رساله دبابات المانيه الصنع تتقدم بولندا
وفنلندا ودول البلطيق بالاقتراح وهي تملك
هذه الدبابات لكنها بحاجه لموافقه المانيه
تعلن بريطانيا ارسالها عدد من دبابات
تشالنجر لكن كيف تريد المزيد يبدو الطريق
غير سالك امام وصول الدبابات الالمانيه
والامريكيه الى جبهات القتال تشترط
المانيا لارسال دباباتها ارسال الولايات
المتحده دباباتها اولا هذا ما تنقله صحيفه
وليتكو عن المستشار الالماني لكن الرجل
يبرر موقفه بالخشيه من الخراط نيته في
الصراع بشكل مباشر تعلل الولايات المتحده
عدم ارسال دباباتها بان الامر يحتاج وقتا
طويلا من التدريب وخشيه من عدم قدره
الاخرانيين على الصيانه
في هذه الازمه المتواصله تتدفق المساعدات
العسكريه الغربيه على اوكرانيا يجتمع
وزراء الدفاع لعدد من دول النيترو من
ضمنهم الوزير البريطاني ويعلنون عن تقديم
المساعدات تتضمن دبابات ويلتقي في الوقت
نفسه وزير الدفاع الامريكي نظيره
الالمانيه في برلين ويشكره على الدعم لكن
بعيدا عن عدسات الكاميرات يتواصل الجدل
ولا انباء عن حل الخلاف حتى الان امام هذا
الجدل الامريكي الالماني والاوروبي
الالماني يغضب الرئيس الاخرانيه وينتقد
المانيا على الملعب
لا تتردد وليست هناك حاجه للمقارنه اذا
قلت انك ستعطي الدبابات شرطه ان يقدم شخص
اخر الدبابات ايضا يبدو لي ان هذه ليست
استراتيجيه صحيحه
ينتقد رئيس الوزراء الهولندي انتقاد
زينسكي لالمانيا انتقاد المانيا ليس صحيحا
المانيا ومنذ بدايه الحرب قدمت الكثير من
الدعم المالي والمعدات
الغربيه
في تفاصيل عسكريه قد تقلب المعادله على
الارض وقد تؤخر الحزم لكنها في الوقت نفسه
قد تحرك مسار الحرب الى طرق مفتوحه
الخياره
[موسيقى]